Game of Thrones has been all about big
revelations lately
beyond the explicit discoveries made by
fans and characters in the show's last
few episodes however the show may have
also inadvertently revealed something
else about its primary villain one fan
theory currently taken the internet by
storm claims that Thrones may have
already spoiled the identity of the
night king though this theory is
circulated through the web since season
7 concluded it found new traction
following HBO's inside the episode
featurette for the season 8 premiere
during the post episode promo Thrones Co
showrunner and director David Benioff
offered up information that many have
taken as evidence that the night king is
in fact a secret Targaryen no one's ever
ridden a dragon except for Danny
the only Targaryen can ride dragons and
that should be a sign for John John's
not always the quickest on the uptake
but eventually he gets there as the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
John's Targaryen blood makes him worthy
to ride a dragon though he doesn't know
it at the time
and while Benioff may be right in saying
that only Targaryen can ride dragons
he's wrong to say that Danny was the
only person to have ridden a dragon
before the first episode of season 8
remember this
that makes three people have written
dragons during the series so far
Daenerys on drogon John and Ragle and
the knight King on Vissarion naturally
this has a huge subsection of a game of
Thrones fandom thinking that the knight
King could be a Targaryen after all of
Dragon Riders our Targaryen z' and the
knight king is a dragon rider then
surely the knight king must be a
Targaryen too
unfortunately it's not hard to pick
holes in this theory for starters
Viserion isn't the same type of dragon
he was before he died he's an ice dragon
now not a fire dragon and it stands the
reason that the old rules don't exactly
apply in this situation and while the
Targaryen do have a deep connection with
dragons they don't appear to have any
historic link to ice dragons according
to Game of Thrones author George RR
Martin's novella the ice dragon humans
can't tame train or ride ice dragons
abortion of the text reads we have tales
of those that tried found frozen with
their whip and harness and hand I've
heard about people that have lost hands
or fingers just by touching one of them
frostbite another problem with the
theory that the night king is a
Targaryen is that the night king is a
member of the first men who came to
Westeros from Essos 12,000 years prior
to the Targaryen conquest after the
first man invaded Westeros the ancient
Westeros II inhabitants known as the
children of the forest captured one of
them and the night king was born neither
House Targaryen nor the Valyrian Empire
from which they came were around during
this time and the Targaryen didn't rise
to power in the Valyrian freehold until
thousands of years after the war between
the first men and the children of the
forest taking this timeline into account
it seems impossible that the first man
who became the night king could have
been a Targaryen on the other hand
there's no getting around one strange
similarity between the night king and
House Targaryen that people picked up on
during the season 8 premiere in one of
the final scenes of the episode Edinson
tall it's beric Dondarrion and others
reached last hearth and find little Lord
umber pinned to a wall with several
severed limbs surrounding his body
mapped out in the shape of a spiral
we've seen that spiral a few times
before
once around the weirwood tree when the
children of the forest created the night
king again when the white walkers
slaughtered horses to terrorize the
wildlings and finally and etchings
carved in the caves of Dragonstone but
it might not be a coup
sannen said the spiral also looks a
whole lot like the sigil of house
targaryen and spirals of a kind have
even been known to appear around the
stories to living Targaryen z' could
this mean that the night king is related
to the Targaryen family in some way
considering his ability to ride Viserion
there really may be some relation then
again maybe there isn't close the bloody
gate check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]